Robert I don't believe anybody else is
doing what you're doing right with
crowds for studios and this is a new
concept is it yeah okay because I
haven't really heard about it yeah are
there anyone else is there any other
company out there or individual who's
doing something similar no no okay there
have been failures in the larger space
like Kevin Spacey had triggers Street
labs I think it was called and forest
whitaker had junto box it was called and
they they're both gone and in my view
because of a couple of basic things they
keep it simple i think is an important
rule just really keep it simple don't
complicate it and we try to do that and
i think we accomplished that addition to
which they were financing their own
pictures we're not doing that so they
really needed a home run or a triple at
least you know the or they couldn't
really diversify so we were in a
position where sin a Wall Street thing
you know just diversify keep it period
and and the other thing I think we're
doing differently I'm certain we're
doing that nobody else is doing is we're
engaging the audience right out of the
gate you know most sites they wait to
make the movie and they deal with the
filmmaking side of it and then they hope
that the audience likes it but our
members are going to be our audience so
the people that are voting for the
scripts and the actors and so forth
presumably are going to be our end users
they're going to watch the movie and we
try to engage them straight up right
right out of the gate house though by
having them vote for the script and so
forth so they you know we tell audiences
you pick what do you want to see what
movie do you want to see made who do you
want to see acting in it and I think
that they'll stick around and watch the
finished product do you plan to have a
social media person that's going to
continue to kind of engage people or
that's a good question yeah the short
answer is yeah definitely it's it's on
the list we have yeah absolutely it's
something I don't have time to do and
and we need a designated person to do so
we're on twitter and we're on facebook
but
we just launched soft launch the site a
few weeks ago so what are your handles
its crowd-sourced I think it's
crowdsource to on Twitter it's all on
the website okay you can yeah there's a
link